[Music]
this is splatsville in the heart of the
splatlands
despite its old-fashioned appearance
it's seen enormous growth in recent
years
it's also the hottest new place for
inklings looking for things to do
oh hello everyone hope you're all
staying fresh i almost forgot about
introductions
we're
the researchers from the squid research
lab
we're simply fascinated by what these
inklings can do
they can splat ink in kit form
and smoothly swim through it in swim
form
we've been studying their biology day
and night
today we'd like to share some new
findings on these inklings while
providing summaries throughout
of course what goes for the inklings
also applies to the octolings we're sure
of it
first turf war
get styling with some fresh fashion and
get inking with even fresher weapons
naturally in a place called splatsville
turf war battles are the local's
favorite pastime
two teams of four will ink for three
minutes
the team that inks the most in their
color in other words claims the most
turf wins
[Music]
now
that's not all inking is for
ink walls to swim up
or get sneaky and hide an ink to splat
opponents
the more ink you spread the bigger the
advantage you'll have in battles
whoops if you're out of ink submerging
it to refill
new techniques like the squid surge to
swim up walls in a single burst and the
squid roll to jump out of ink while
simultaneously turning around have also
been spotted
[Music]
oh while it's glowing like this
the move also slightly repels ink from
opponents
we've discovered where these turf war
battles will take place
stages confirmed for the splatlands
include
scorch gorge
field tail alley
mincemeat metalworks
and undertow spillway
there seem to be other stages as well
hagglefish market a pier filled to the
brim with street vendors the stuff here
looks fishy though
several stages from greater inkopolis
also return
museum del fonsino
battles here take place in the central
courtyard of this modern museum
take special note of the rotating wall
hammerhead bridge
this bridge connects greater inkopolis
to the splat lands after lots of
construction work it's finally open
thanks to the bridge transit to and from
greater inkopolis is much easier
mahi mahi resort
a luxury resort in greater inkopolis
pay close attention to the platforms
that sink as the battle goes on
there will be more areas to ink
afterward so don't forget to splat them
including the stages you see here a
total of 1208
more stages will be added in free post
launch updates
now let's get into the inky essence of
battles
weapons
first it appears that all the basic
weapons from previous games will be
available
on top of that splat land specific
weapon types such as the bow-like
stringers will make their destructive
debut
we've also verified a new weapon type
called splatanas
this is the splatana wiper
send blades of ink flying with the
centrifugal force generated by swinging
swing after charging up a bit and it'll
transform into a charged slash
as expected it's powerful as a
long-range attack
but the charged slash at close range is
also quite devastating
[Music]
let's dive into the weapons that can
help you claim even more turn special
weapons
as the name implies these are special
kinds of weapons that can be unleashed
after filling up the gauge from inking
turf
there are some new types we've
identified so let's take a closer look
this is the tacticooler when it's
activated a fridge appears you'll find
in-game beverages stored inside these
have a variety of effects like
momentarily increasing speed
they come in packs of four so take one
and share the rest with your teammates
this is the wave breaker when activated
it'll unleash waves around the area
it'll also mark an opponent's location
and cause damage
try to avoid them with a well-timed jump
finally the reef slider
build up power then charge into
opponents who need a good splat
once the attack ends it'll explode and
damage the surrounding area familiar
special weapons like the tenta missiles
inkjet
ink storm
ultrastan
and booyah bomb will also make their
grand return
special weapons are paired with main
weapons so find the combo that suits
your splatting style
shop here to get your tentacles on some
fresh weapons
this is ammo nights owned by the chatty
horseshoe crab sheldon
the locals have praised him for his
wealth of weapon wisdom and
sophisticated selection
instead of using in-game currency for
purchases you'll need these sheldon
licenses obtain them by leveling up
through battles
and by consistently using the same
weapons
one sheldon license can be exchanged for
one weapon that corresponds to your
level
oh and just between us if you exchange
more sheldon licenses than normal it
appears he'll give you a weapon you like
sooner than expected as a special reward
by the way the inklings and octolings
walking around town are pretty savvy
about their fashion
things like headgear clothing and shoes
are just as important as weapons to
staying fresh in splatsville
[Music]
gear can be obtained in the shops around
here
one is managed by an interesting
shopkeeper so let's drop in
this is not couture a headgear shop
you'll find an array of hats masks and
glasses so you can get ahead of the game
[Music]
the laid-back nautilus gnarly eddy and
the energetic nails the snail sitting
here run the shop
this is the clothes boutique mana
wardrobe
it specializes in tops like t-shirts and
jackets
the shopkeeper gel lafleur might be a
touch archaic with words but this
jellyfish has a keen eye for fashion
sense
and finally the shoe store crush station
get a variety of cool kicks here from
sneakers to sandals and even leather
footwear
it's owned by mr coco he might look
intimidating but deep down he's a nice
guy
probably
you're more than welcome to pick out
gear based on its appearance
but they do come with abilities that can
help you out in battle
take run speed up for example
it can increase your running speed
or intensify action this improves the
squid roll and squid surge moves
there are even more abilities to
discover
plus there's a fellow in splat spill who
can swap one ability with another
talk to merch here and you can add an
ability of your choosing to your
favorite gear
and if you save your favorite gear
combinations as fresh as fits you can
change in a flash
flavor up your fashion with whatever
outfits you want simply splat-tastic
[Music]
welcome to the lobby a gathering spot
for those seeking fresh battles
turf war battles aren't the only things
that happen here you can also square off
in anarchy battles where you compete for
rankings
hold the active zones in splex zones
ride the tower to the goal in tower
control
carry the rainmaker to its destination
in rainmaker
or collect and throw clams to score in
clam blitz
duke it out in these four modes which
are on rotation
wanna take on a challenge solo select
anarchy battle series but if you want to
team up with friends joining anarchy
battle open is the way to go
you can also play private battles online
set battle modes and other options to
your liking why not play with your
favorite battle modes alongside friends
information about these game modes will
be available soon on the game's official
website
now let's talk about the features within
the lobby
this is the test range
try out and get comfy with your weapons
here
besides being able to practice whenever
you want
it's also a great place to get all
warmed up while waiting for rivals to
join a battle
next up
ghosts online friends will appear as 3d
holograms
drop in on friends in the midst of
battle and play alongside them
you can also join up and start a battle
on the same team
you'll be able to see what your friends
are up to
it appears that you can also call out to
friends in the lobby and invite them for
battles
why not see these features for yourself
this is where you can view battle
replays
it appears that it can somewhat recreate
recent battles
fast forward
or skip to a certain part
or even swap to another player's view
incredible
not only can you re-watch battles as
many times as you'd like but there's
even a share feature
we hope you'll use this handy tool to
help you rank up
next
we'll analyze and discuss this space
within the lobby the locker room
here you'll find some fresh lockers
one is yours and the others belong to
players with whom you've recently played
as you can see you'll be able to place
any acquired weapons gear and items to
your liking
slap on some snazzy stickers
and modify your locker's color
this is your space to express yourself
so customize it however you'd like to
show off your signature splatting style
[Music]
oh yes items can be obtained at
hotlantis a general store on the edge of
splatsville
apparently the store manager vanishes
quite often so instead it's run by an
artist named harmony she used to be a
regular customer here
it's got an outlandish assortment of
items
why not show the store some love by
grabbing some goods
there appear to be plenty of other
customization features as well
when battles start these splash tags
appear
they can be customized with a banner
badge
and title
additionally you can change the emote
your character performs when you win a
battle
all of these can be obtained via the
in-game catalog which will be available
at hotlantis
by using points earned from battles you
can unlock various items like stuff for
splash tags and seasonal gear
[Music]
following the game's launch a new
catalog is planned to be released every
three months for two years
be sure to snatch up everything you see
in each catalog
phew
there's still a lot of info to share but
i need to take a little breather here
in the meantime please turn your
attention toward this
introducing
table turf battle
lay out your cars for a dazzling deck
duel
ink different shapes with different
cards
charge up power then unleash it all at
once with a special attack
there are cards like this and even ones
like this and there are over 150 cards
to collect in game
so build your deck and send your rivals
packing
the splatsville locals eagerly awaits
your challenge
table turf battle
every player will be gifted an in-game
starter deck
excuse me i lost my clam poosier for a
second there
that was table turf battle a 1v1
competitive card battle spin-off of turf
war
it appears you can play this at the
table turf battle dojo in splatsville
be on the lookout for more details about
table turf battle in the future
and now
this
salmon run is a simple job that requires
four players to work together to collect
power eggs from the salmonids advancing
on them this part-time gig is rumored to
be a little fishy but it pays pretty
well
by defeating particularly ferocious
creatures called boss salmonids you can
obtain valuable golden eggs
you'll need to collect and deliver
plenty of golden eggs in order to
complete this job
this time around we've confirmed some
new types of boss salmonids so let's
share our findings
first up the slammin lid
it creates barriers and protects
salmonids on the ground
get too close to it and it'll attempt to
crush you so approach with caution
[Music]
next the big shot
it fires heavy projectiles from a
distance
be prepared for powerful shock waves
when they land
with new boss salmon it's confirmed make
sure you're ready for an even more
dangerous salmon run
[Music]
this is
one of the new king salmonids
unbelievable
it looks like they'll occasionally
appear just before you complete the job
[Music]
the tank on your back is a specially
provided egg cannon and it appears that
you can fire golden eggs to deal massive
damage
[Music]
however these battles are under a time
limit so rack up as much damage as
possible to drive them back
[Music]
and this this is the still being
researched big run
we believe this is when salmonids invade
the city in which icklings and octolings
live
it appears that this event happens once
every few months so brace yourselves
big run is coming
[Music]
now observe this manhole in splatsville
square
this is actually the entrance to the
home of the octarians the inklings
longtime enemies
as agent 3 the newest recruit of the new
squid beak splatoon he'll do battle with
the octarian army whose members are
covered in hair for some reason
along with your buddy small fry you'll
explore many stages each one full of
twists and turns
oh i almost forgot story mode is perfect
for getting familiar with inking turf
and using weapons some newer players
might want to try it out
well we've come this far
what awaits the inklings and octolings
in the end we hope you can witness the
epic finale of this splat-tastic saga
we're back in splatsville from here on
out we'd like to talk about other
features that'll help you enjoy your
splatting escapades even more in the
splatoon 3 game
you can post illustrations here via this
mailbox
they'll be displayed all across the city
and even in stages
so put on your artist cap and post away
vertical illustrations will also be
supported
additionally you can grab food and
drinks that'll help you in battles at
the concession stand
or use local communication to play with
nearby folks in your favorite modes at
the show
by using photo mode you can snap selfies
send photos to a smart device
or display them in your locker
this is the recon guide
select your favorite stages at any time
and take a stroll around them
why not get familiar with each stage
prior to battles
this is splatnet 3.
you can use this with your smart device
it contains features like checking your
latest battle stats
and ordering special in-game gear not
sold in shops from the splatnet gear
shop
but that's not all
access features like krusty sean's
wonder crust
support this fellow's journey using ink
points earned depending on the areas you
inked during battles
or view history to take a trip down
memory lane with your past ranks
you can also snag special wallpapers and
more for your smart device so be sure to
grab them
it appears that splatnet 3 will be
available at launch via the nintendo
switch online mobile app
[Music]
next up amiibo figures scan splatoon
series amiibo at this spot in
splatsville and voila saving your
favorite gear combinations as freshest
fits will allow you to easily swap
outfits
additionally it seems you'll be able to
get special gear and even snap photos
together with amiibo
and splatoon 3 amiibo incoming
release is scheduled for this holiday
now let's talk about post launch updates
as we mentioned a while ago
following the game's launch a new
in-game catalog will be released every
three months for two years
new weapons will also be added around
the same time as each catalog
in addition x battle available after
attaining an extremely high rank in
anarchy battle
and league battle where every two hours
you can compete in teams based on your
anarchy battle results are planned to be
added in future updates
furthermore for this game we're planning
to add large-scale paid dlc
more details will come at a later time
so please be on the lookout and now i'd
like to wrap up this research report
from the squid research lab thank you
for watching
huh who are you supposed to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh squid
i completely forgot to tell you about
deep cut
they're an incredibly popular trio who
hosts the splatsville news program
anarchy splatcast
they provide information on battle
stages as well as other news bulletins
while we're on the subject the
youngsters of splatsville own sea
cucumber phones they can check the news
while doing other activities as shown
here
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been confirmed that splatfest will
make a return
in these events you pick a team based on
the announced theme then settle the
outcome via battle
and this time around there will be three
teams to choose from
splatfests consist of two halves
in the first half teams will compete in
four v4 turf war battles
the second half
is a tri-color turf war
it's a special mode where
whoa
three teams fight at the same time
all players on the team currently in
first place will start in the center of
the stage
two players each from the second and
third place teams will attack the first
place team from opposite ends of the
stage
can the leading team defend themselves
or will the other two teams exact
revenge and force them out use the ultra
signal to control the battle and
contribute to the splatfest while
working alongside the members of deep
cut
[Music]
okay we're going to close out this
presentation with an announcement from
deep cut take it away
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's all we have to share today
or not
and now announcing
the splatoon 3 enter the splatlands
invitational 2022 tournament
this event will take place on september
5th at pax west
some of the top finishers from this
summer splatoon 2 inkopolis showdown
will head to seattle and compete in
north america's first ever splatoon 3
invitational
follow the official nintendo vs twitter
account for updates
and to see more of our research findings
as we uncover them follow the official
splatoon north american twitter account
we hope you'll have an incredible time
starting september 9th bye bye